the ListView starts by requesting of you
for every visible item however many you
can fit onto the screen it'll also
create a couple in either direction to
make sure that we can scroll without
seeing a flicker as a new viewers
created and populated then it creates
new items just in time so it's next in
line to be visible to the user so if the
user never Scrolls the bottom of the
list the list view will never request
that view from the adapter but this is
really just a half measure as you can
see if the user keeps scrolling we could
potentially just keep adding new views
even if they disappear off the top of
the screen eventually that's going to
lead to the same impact in memory use
and performance as if we had just
created all of these views directly at
the beginning the solution is recycling
each view as it Scrolls off the screen
allowing it to be reused when we need to
show another item as it moves into view
at the top or bottom so rather than
having to create and then hold in memory
each item of the list as it comes into
view we only need to do the creation
step for the number of visible items and
a couple on either side then whenever a
new list item comes into view we just
update the data displayed in one of the
items in our recycle bin the result less
memory overhead smoother scrolling and
less view management you have to do
yourself
this same recycling behavior is
implemented across all adaptive you
descended classes such as gridview and
listview which also introduces the
reason that the adapter isn't built
directly into these controls themself by
keeping them separate your adapter
defines how to display each element of
the underlying data while the adaptive
view implementation itself is
responsible for controlling how each of
these elements is laid out be it a list
or a grid in these particular instances